KATIE GRAY: Hi, everyone.
Good afternoon.
My name is Katie Gray, and I
work at the presentation design
firm Duarte, where
these ladies lead.
And I actually used
to work at Google,
so it's exciting to
be back here and I'm
honored to introduce them.
So Nancy Duarte, she's
the CEO of Duarte.
It's a firm that's
created over a quarter
of a million presentations
over the past 28 years
in Silicon Valley.
And Nancy has written
five bestselling books
about using visual storytelling
in business communications,
including "Resonate" and
"Slideology" and the latest
book, "Illuminate," which
we'll be talking about today.
Her work has been featured in
"Fortune," "Wired," "The Wall
Street Journal," "New
York Times," many,
many other places.
And Patti Sanchez is the chief
strategy officer of Duarte.
She has over 25
years of experience
leading transformative
marketing initiatives
for global brands like Adobe,
Cisco, Ericsson, Nike, VMWare,
GE, and many more.
Her lifelong passion is
helping communicators
engage empathetically
and authentically.
So Nancy and Patti
are going to speak
to you about their new book
"Illuminate-- Ignite Change
Through Speeches, Stories
Ceremonies, and Symbols."
If any of you have tried to
convince a group of people
to go on a long, arduous journey
somewhere, even though you knew
it was worth it but you
had to convince them,
then this book is for you.
The book is a result
of years of research
into many, many
business case studies
from the likes of Steve
Jobs or Mary Barra
or Lou Gerstner at IBM,
and it's very informative.
I think you'll
very much enjoy it.
And today you're going to
hear about some key principles
in that book to help you
lead people to a vision.
So with that, I'd
like to welcome
Nancy Duarte and Patti Sanchez.
[APPLAUSE]
PATTI SANCHEZ: Thanks,
Katie-- Katie Gray.
I love working with her,
and I also love talking.
So she might know.
I love talking
about storytelling.
As Katie said, we're big fans of
visual storytelling at Duarte.
And I assume that
you're all fans of it,
to some degree, which
is why you're here.
And a lot of people recognize
the power of storytelling
as a communication tool,
especially for marketers.
A lot of brands use
storytelling to create affection
for their products
and to get people
to fall in love with their
companies and the things
that they offer.
But what a lot of people
maybe don't realize
is that storytelling is
actually a leadership tool.
And so we're going
to talk to you today
about how leaders
and people like
you can use
storytelling to inspire
others to do big things.
And really, we think
that the job of a leader
is to create the future.
So what does that really mean?
Well, first of all, I
think it's the difference
between a manager and a
leader is that a manager is
somebody who maintains what is.
They just keep the
current thing going.
A leader is somebody who
creates what could be.
They make something new possible
that didn't exist before.
And it's not an easy thing to
do to create something new.
And you may not even think
of yourself as a leader,
but if you're
doing anything that
makes a new future possible,
then you are a leader.
You are taking people
into a territory
that they've never
been in before,
which can be creating a new
feature, in launching it
to the world.
It can be building a
process of some kind.
It can be hiring
or training people.
All of those things
create a capability
that didn't exist before
to make something new.
The challenges that
that new future
you're trying to bring into
being actually represents
change.
Because you're envisioning
something that didn't yet
exist, you're going to have
to get other people to agree
that this new thing
is a good idea
and to get them to help
you make it a reality.
And that's not easy, because
most people don't like change.
Some of you might
actually be kind of
comfortable with
change, especially
if you have an entrepreneurial
kind of spirit.
Then maybe the white
space excites you.
But the average human being
is frightened by that.
They're frightened
by the unknown,
because it requires
them to do things,
to learn things that
they don't understand.
And that's stretchy.
And so whenever you
introduce a new idea,
you're effectively asking people
to do something differently
than what they've done before.
And most people are going
to resist that in some way.
And it may not even look
like outright revolt to you.
It might just sound like doubt.
They might say, how do we
know that's the best idea,
or how do we know it's better
than the way things happen
right now.
Or maybe the way we used to
do things was the right way
to do things.
And all of those are
signs that they're
going to resist this change.
And so if you have
an idea and you
want to motivate people to help
you make that idea a reality,
you actually have to have
a plan for how you're
going to lead them
on what we call
a venture-- a venture
into the future.
So venture is an
interesting word,
because it has two meanings.
Especially in Silicon
Valley, a lot of people
think of a venture as
sort of like a startup.
It's a noun that means
it's a new thing.
But a venture is also a verb.
It's actually the act
of going somewhere.
And it's also sort of like
metaphorically an adventure,
an expedition into a
territory that people
haven't been in before.
So if you think about traveling
to a place you've never been to
before, what is helpful?
It's often helpful to
have a map, some way
to visually understand where
you are and where you need to go
and what the path
might be between them.
So what is a map of a venture
into the future potentially
look like?
Well, we think there's a
common symbol in business that
actually describes what
this journey looks like,
and it's the s-curve
of innovation.
And what it does is it describes
the life cycle of a business
or of an idea from its
beginning to its end,
from its start to its
growth to its maturity.
And the challenge is that when
that idea or the organization
that's created that
idea reaches maturity,
then stagnation sets in.
Because as I said,
people don't like change.
So they're going to
dig in their heels
and say, let's just
enjoy the way things are.
Now that we've got it
working, let's just ride this.
But if you don't
evolve, if that idea
doesn't continue
to grow and evolve,
then that stagnation can lead
to a decline or even death,
this downward slide.
So it's the job of a leader
to imagine another future
and lead another venture to
go there, and to do it again
and to do it again.
Because for organizations
and even people to thrive,
they have to constantly
reinvent themselves.
So what leaders have
to do is figure out
how to bring people
along with them.
And we've worked with
all kinds of leaders
in our years of consulting
at Duarte and before that.
And we've studied what the
greatest leaders do to bring
people along with them.
And we've found that they're
all great communicators.
But they also use specific
kinds of communication tools
to bring people along with them.
So we're going to talk
a bit about those.
This is what we consider the
toolkit that great leaders use
to bring people along
with them on that venture
into the future.
The first is telling stories.
They also deliver speeches
and they hold ceremonies.
So stories are a great
communication tool,
because they engage people.
They make us feel something.
If you watch a really
interesting movie,
you know that you get caught
up in it, and you have all the
feels-- the joy and
the pain and the fear.
And the same is true of stories
that we tell in our lives.
And that leaders
can tell is a way
to create an emotional
connection with the people
that they're talking to.
So they cause us
to feel something.
And actually, when I'm
telling you a story,
my brain waves actually start to
align with yours or yours align
with mine, because we're
feeling the same thing together
at the same time.
And that same connection happens
between the people who are all
hearing the story together.
So it's actually a way
to unite groups of people
around a common experience.
Now, another reason why stories
are a really powerful tool
for leading people is because
stories are about change.
Fundamentally at their
heart, Annie's story
is about a person who has to go
through a journey of some kind
and ultimately is
transformed by it.
And that's really what a
definition of a story is.
And there's a lot of
confusion out there,
a lot of people
talking about story
and saying that
they're storytellers,
when we don't think they're
necessarily true stories
that they're communicating.
So this is the definition
in its purest form of story.
Goes all the way
back to Aristotle.
And he said, a story
has three parts.
It has a beginning,
a middle, and an end.
In the beginning, we
meet the likable hero.
This is the protagonist.
This is the person who's
just trying to do life.
And then something happens,
an inciting incident
they call it, that throws
that hero's world off balance
and usually actually causes them
to leave that place, that home
and go somewhere new.
And in the process of
traveling from what
they know to this
new territory, they
encounter all
kinds of roadblocks
in the middle of that story,
because it's all new territory.
They might have to fight
monsters or aliens.
And they even are challenged
to their inner core,
and often end up
questioning who they are
and what they're capable of.
But ultimately, at
the end of the story,
through grit and determination,
they overcome those obstacles
and they come out the other
side, different, transformed.
So that's why stories are
actually a really powerful way
to help people cope with
change, because they describe
the process of change itself.
Now, there's another tool
that leaders use-- whoops,
before that-- this is
actually the shape of a story.
And what you can see here is
that the middle of the story
is where all the action
happens, literally action.
The rising action
increases tension,
and the falling action
releases that tension.
And it's that
increase of tension
and the release of tension that
keeps us engaged in the story.
It creates contrast.
Now, as I was about
to say, there's
another tool that leaders
use to communicate.
And you probably recognize this.
You may do it yourself
and not realize
that you're giving a speech.
But speeches are not
just the big talks,
like the vision thing,
when the leader stands up
in front of the
organization and says,
this is where we're
going this year.
A speech is also a
progress update-- here's
where we are in our project.
Here's what we're
going to do next.
A speech is also an announcement
about good news or bad news.
All of those are opportunities,
not just to inform people
about what's happening
and what's next,
but also to inspire
them and engage them.
Now, we've studied also
storytelling principles
and how they can be
applied to speeches.
And a few years ago, Nancy
made an incredible discovery
that there's a pattern
to the speeches
that the greatest
communicators give.
So she can do a better
job of explaining it,
so I'm going to send her up.
NANCY DUARTE: So after
spending about four years
studying storytelling,
I was wondering
why some speeches have this
cadence and a rhythm to it.
It's like it builds
tension and released it
and it would build
tension and release.
You were drawn in.
So after doing a
journey through story
and then going through the 100
top best speeches of all time,
I actually found
what that pattern is,
and it is based in the tension
and release of storytelling.
And so I want to show you
the shape that I discovered.
This is a structural
shape over time.
It has a beginning,
a middle, and an end.
And that pulsing and the cadence
is the building of tension
and releasing it
from storytelling.
Now, this has a
three act structure,
just like a great story does.
So the beginning of any-- I'm
going to say presentations,
but this works for any
type of communication.
It works for email.
This could work for a blog post.
It helps me get my husband
to do chores on the weekend.
Like, it works.
It persuades.
So the beginning is you
need to establish what is.
And what you're doing
is, you're basically
saying, what's our shared truth?
This is what we all
believe as true.
This is the state of the union.
This is the budget.
This is where we're
at financially.
That's kind of what you do.
And then what happens is
you insert what could be.
And this is like the
inciting incident in a story.
Suddenly your world
is out of balance,
and that gap between
what is and what
could be winds up
being what gets
resolved through the
rest of your talk.
The middle moves back
and forth structurally
between what is, what could
be, what is and what could be.
So the human brain is
wired for contrast,
and we can actually see the gap.
The audience can see, oh,
if that's what currently is,
but this is what
could be, suddenly
what is isn't
interesting, and what
could be is more appealing.
So that's how it works
as a structural tool.
The last vertical line
is the call to action.
And every talk should have one.
But you shouldn't end there.
You should end
with the new bliss.
This is you describing
this future state
that's going to be amazing
if everyone adopts your idea.
It's the new bliss,
the new norm.
So once I had this shape,
I've analyzed so many talks.
I want to just show you some.
I have done a TED talk
that goes into detail,
but I just want to
show you some quickly,
because we've analyzed
a ton of them.
So we have Margaret Thatcher
in her "Iron Lady" speech.
You can see, she starts
off with what is.
She's pretty rapid.
When she talked to Parliament,
was a kind of this one punch,
two punch, like
what is, what could
be, what is, what
could be, all the time.
So you can see she
starts off with what
is and moves back and
forth between what is
and what could be, ending
high into the right stating
the new bliss.
Richard Feynman, very
famous Caltech professor--
he was a physics
professor and kids
would run across campus
to see his class, even
if they didn't need to take it.
He was known as "The
Great Explainer."
He did a law of
gravity speech, and you
can see it's a technical speech,
yet it moves really rapidly
between what is
and what could be.
Steve Jobs, "iPhone
Launch" speech--
he has a heightened
sense of what
could be in all of
his speeches, but it
does move back and forth between
what is and what could be.
And of course Dr. King's
very famous "I Have a Dream"
speech also starts off with
what is, moves back and forth.
Now, you can see the frequency
get really tight about 2/3 in.
That was his very
famous, "I Have a Dream"
sequence-- "I have a
dream that one day-- I
have a dream that one day--."
What's interesting
is some of the most
beloved parts of our
most beloved speeches
are the gap between
what is and what
could be at the
phrase level, as they
move back and forth between
"I have a dream that one day."
He did not call this the
"I Have a Dream" speech.
He actually called it "The
Fierce Urgency of Now."
That was the actual
official title.
The people named it
the "I Have a Dream"
speech because of this very
beloved sequence right here.
So those are pretty
lofty people.
I just work at Google.
I just have this
thing I need to do.
I'm not reviving the
civil rights movement.
So I'll bring it closer to home,
using an example of a female.
And it's my 11-year-old niece.
She wrote a letter to her dad
because she wanted a mouse.
Now, in an
11-year-old mind, this
is the most important thing
in her life right now.
So she writes an
impassioned plea that
follows the form perfectly.
She says, "Dear Dad,
we want a mouse.
And you might say they're
stinky, but they're not
if you put special
drops in the water.
You might say that they're
mean, but you rarely
find an aggressive mouse.
If they do bite, it's usually
just a curiosity nibble.
I know you will not
want to pay for it,
and Sophie and I
have that covered.
We've saved our birthday money
so we can pay for the mouse
and everything else,
and you will not
have to pay a single cent.
Also the mouse will be
in Sophie's or my room,
so you will not see
it all the time.
And the new bliss is we will
respect any decision you make."
They got the mouse.
So you can see
what's interesting
to me is, it's almost
like we're hardwired.
She's not seen my books,
come to my workshop.
I did not design
this letter for her.
She wanted it so bad, she used
a persuasive story pattern
with the tension and
release of story.
So it's amazing
when you really need
to give an impassioned
plea, how important that is.
So one of the third
story-based concepts
that we're introducing into
the business vernacular
is the idea of ceremonies.
And ceremonies-- some of the
oldest artifacts we can find
are actually artifacts
that were used in ritual
because a group of people felt
they needed communal catharsis
around their community.
And so it's also based in
the same three act structure
that story is.
But the naming
conventions are different.
We looked at the rites
of passage, because that
is the most common
in society today--
a marriage, a graduation,
a bar mitzvah.
Because we are both
married to Hispanic men,
we're going to use the
quinceanera as an example.
And what that is, is when
a young girl turns 15,
she goes through
rites of passage
similar to a bar mitzvah.
But she comes in a little flat
shoes and a drabby little dress
and she's carrying a dolly.
So what she's doing
is she's actually
going to be separating from
that version of her identity.
She goes through a ceremony,
and she transitions.
The minute the ceremony is
done, suddenyl she's a woman.
So she gets rid of her doll.
She gets to wear high heels,
puts on a little tiara,
and she's a woman now.
All that happened was
three minutes of time.
She went from being
a little girl,
and suddenly she's a woman
just because of the ceremony.
Now, ceremonies--
what they do is they
mark endings and beginnings.
This is over.
I'm not a little girl.
I've let go of my girlish
things and I am a woman now.
Well, corporations need
to practice the concept
of endings and beginnings.
Because when you're
trying to transform
a collective
consciousness of people,
there are things
that end and there
are things that begin again.
It's very important
to understand
endings and beginnings and
the power that they hold.
If people can let go
of the old, they're
more willing to embrace the new.
And we have a case study
in a minute about that.
So this is the basic
toolkit that communicators
need as you're driving
your own teams.
And I'll bring Patti
back up here again
to talk about how to do that.
PATTI SANCHEZ:
Well, that toolkit
that Nancy recaptures there is
what we call a torchbearer's
toolkit.
And the reason we use
the word torchbearer
is because it's the
job of the leader
to illuminate the path between
the present and the future.
Again, when you think
about this metaphorically
as an expedition
to a place people
have never been to
before into the unknown,
metaphorically that
unknown is sort
of a dark and scary place to
people, or at least it's foggy.
It's hard for them
to visualize it
and to understand it and
feel safe going there.
So through effective
communication,
leaders basically
light that pass
so that people can see
where they need to go
and how to get there.
And if leaders
communicate really well,
they create moments that
move people, moments
that make people feel
bigger, more capable
than they realized
that they were.
And they create the
capacity for people
to do things that they
didn't realize they could do.
But the bigger your
idea is, the more change
you're going to
ask people to make.
And the more change
you ask people to make,
the more you're going to have
to persuade them to actually go
there, which means you're
going to have to communicate
over and over and over, because
transformational change doesn't
happen overnight.
What it's going to take
is actually a movement.
And what is a movement anyway?
A movement is a
massive group of people
going somewhere
together, usually
over a long period of time.
It can be weeks, but often
it's months or years or even
decades.
And we've had many leaders say
to us they wanted to create
movements around their ideas.
And that launched
us on this quest
to understand how
movements actually happen
and what they really look like.
And so as we mapped the
forms that communication
can take, the shape of a
story, the shape of a speech,
we wondered, is there actually
a shape to movement too?
And we studied business
movements, like OpenSource.
We studied social movements,
like civil rights.
And we looked at all
the things that leaders
did, all the communication
that they gave,
and how that unfolded over time.
And we discovered
that they do actually
follow a shape,
which is magically
the s-curve of innovation,
which is basically mapping
the path between what is,
the present state, and what
could be, which is the future.
But we also discovered that
those movements follow a story
structure too, just
like the communication
that you use to move people.
And so this is that
story structure
of a movement, which we
call a venture scape.
It's that landscape of the
venture into the future.
So it has three acts, just
like a story, with five stages.
In the first act are the
dream and leap stages.
Dream happens when you--
the leader, whoever's
the advocate for an idea--
declares the vision.
You say, this is what I see.
This is where I want us to go.
Let's go there.
But immediately, as soon as
you communicate that vision,
people are faced with a
choice about whether they're
going to say yes, I'm
in, or whether they're
going to say no, I'm out.
So they have a choice
to commit or resist.
And how well you
communicate directly
affects how likely
they are to say yes.
And when they do
say yes, when they
leap into this venture with you,
then in the middle of the story
starts to unfold.
In the middle, just
like in a great story
that you might see in a movie
is where all the action happens.
And translated in
real life, that
means where all the
hard stuff happens.
Because in the middle are
the fight and climb stages.
The fight is when
anybody is trying
to bring that idea to reality.
The status quo
rises up against it.
Anybody who's defending the
way things are and the fact
that they should stay the same
is going to put up resistance.
And so people have to
overcome those obstacles.
They have to fight
that internal inertia
or the external
criticism of this idea.
But every time they overcome
one of those obstacles,
they gain a little more ground.
They climb a little
closer, get a little closer
to that end goal.
And the middle is
really the hard part.
It's where people are tested,
just like in the story.
That hero comes to question
whether they have the stuff
to continue.
And how well you
communicate will
determine whether they
think they can finish.
And that's when the
third act of the story
comes to an end, which
is the arrive stage.
The arrive stage is where
you achieve your goal,
or at least you
conclude that effort.
And it could be a happy
ending, like in the movies.
But most likely, it
won't be perfectly happy.
You might fall short of
your goal a little bit.
You might not achieve what
you thought you would.
It might change shape.
But at that point
in the journey,
it's important to look back,
to say, what did we actually
accomplish?
Where did we fall short, and
how do we avoid those mistakes
in the future?
Also, you have to
communicate frequently
throughout this process.
And your communication has to
take on a different flavor,
depending on the stage of
the journey that you're in,
because people have different
emotional needs at each stage.
In the beginning of the
journey, that first stage
in dream, what they need
is a moment of inspiration.
They need to believe
in that idea.
They need to be able to imagine
themselves in that future
and long to go there.
In the leap stage,
what they really need
is a moment of decision.
They need help choosing
whether to say yes
or whether to say no.
And hopefully, they'll say yes.
The fight stage is
a moment of bravery.
That's when people need to
be reminded that they're
capable of overcoming
those obstacles,
to feel courageous,
willing to risk anything
to fight, to make
your idea a reality.
The climb stage, which
is kind of a misnomer,
because it can be a very
long, drawn-out process
of getting closer to the goal.
And what people really
need then is endurance.
They need to be reminded
that they have reserves
deep inside of themselves
that they can call upon
so that they can overcome, keep
going, and ultimately finish.
And in the end, what people
need is a moment of reflection.
This is a time to stop, to catch
your breath, before you rush
off to the next initiative to
tell the stories of what you
just went through,
to celebrate them
or to mourn the endings before
they start the next journey.
So I want to tell
you about one leader
that I think did
this really well.
And his name may not
be familiar to you,
but I have a lot of
affection for him.
His name is Ray Anderson, and
he was the CEO and founder
of a company called Interface.
Interface was
founded in the 1970s.
When Ray had this idea, it
was kind of crazy at the time
to create carpet
tiles-- basically take
big rolls of carpet and cut
them up into squares, because he
thought it was a good idea.
And so he convinced
a few investors
to give him some money, and
he started this business.
And it turned out to be the
right idea at the right time,
because office
environments were changing,
and so this modular carpeting
was a really good concept.
And so he grew that
business like gangbusters.
For 20 years, it became the
world's largest supplier
of carpet tiles.
And he was making
money hand over fist,
a self-made millionaire.
And everything was
great until the 1990s,
when everybody started
to wake up to the climate
problem, the
environmental problems
that we were all experiencing.
And they were
starting to criticize
industrial businesses,
who they believed
were causing the problems.
And so customers
even started asking
Ray, what are you doing
for the environment?
And he was really
troubled by the question,
because he couldn't answer it.
His only answer
was, I'm just trying
to stay out of jail, which
is not a good strategy.
So coincidentally, an employee
sent him a copy of this book,
"The Ecology of
Commerce," by Paul Hawken,
one of the founders
of Smith and Hawken.
And so Ray devoured this
book, looking for an answer
to that question.
And what he saw was this.
He said, "He convicted me as a
plunderer of the earth," which
is a horrible thing to hear,
especially for a founder.
He said, I built this company
that is plundering the earth.
And he said it hit him
like a spear in the chest.
He would tell people
that story over and over
about the epiphany that he had.
And he was compelled to
come up with a new dream
for his company.
And this is how
he articulated it.
He said, what if
Interface became
the first industrial
company in the world
to achieve sustainability?
And he used a story,
metaphorical journey
of climbing a mountain
taller than Everest
to describe this vision.
And he always drew this
picture to depict it.
And he would use
that over and over
in his communications to
help people really understand
and imagine themselves
achieving that goal.
He knew it going to take a lot
of work to make that happen.
So he called all of his
leaders together for an offsite
in Maui, Hawaii, and
he asked Paul Hawken
to actually give the keynote.
So Paul Hawken stood up and he
talked about all the problems
that were affecting the
planet, but also all the things
that individuals can do, this
global village, to turn things
around, to make a difference.
And then Ray got up and spoke.
And he asked every
single one of his leaders
to make a personal commitment
to do something different,
to put the environment
back in balance.
But he didn't just ask them.
He asked them to
demonstrate that commitment
in front of everybody
right then and there.
So they all wrote
pledges on cards
that they pinned up next
to photos of themselves
on what they called a
personal legacy wall.
It was a ceremony of pledging
commitment to change.
And after that ceremony,
the leaders were galvanized.
They raced forward
and they kicked off
all kinds of initiatives
across the company
to do things
differently, to transform
the way they did business.
And over the next 20
years, they really
changed everything top to bottom
in the company, everything
about how they operated.
And they also transformed
their industry.
So why do I tell you this
story about Ray Anderson?
There are a couple reasons.
One, because he's an
entrepreneur, somebody
who made something
out of nothing,
and I think that's
really inspiring.
Two, because he put
his entire business
in service of a purpose greater
than profit, which I also think
is really inspiring.
But three, because
he was a leader who
understood the power of
communication and storytelling
and used it to motivate people
to do really big things.
He's not the only one.
There are a lot of leaders
who did this really well,
and so Nancy is going to
tell you about one more.
NANCY DUARTE: So I want to do
a quick case study about Apple.
As you guys know, Steve Jobs was
kicked out of his own company,
went away for 10 years and
built a different company
with a different
operating system.
But in the time that Mr.
Jobs was gone from Apple,
Apple had no strategy.
They tried a few times to create
an operating system and failed.
So they had to go
outside of Apple,
look to buy an operating system.
They bought Next and
with Next came Mr. Jobs.
The very first time
Mr. Jobs spoke,
even though it was
a broad audience,
it was not at a
developers' conference--
the news was there.
It was a MacWorld.
He spoke as if he
was only talking
to the developers in the room.
He had 20 minutes, and he used
the word "developer" 27 times,
because he knew
the developers had
to move from Mac OS 9 to Mac
OS X or the whole company
would fail.
It was huge.
Now, Gil Emilio spoke
for three hours,
and he said the word
"developer" three times.
No wonder he wasn't
the right guy to lead.
But you've got to
realize Apple was
in a complete
crisis at this time.
The developers were
very, very skeptical
because they had been
jerked around for a decade.
They'd do a build, and the next
year they'd find out everything
was wasted.
They'd do another build
and it was wasted.
So they were very skeptical.
In fact, Mr Jobs
did a talk actually
called "Apple's
Hierarchy of Skepticism"
where he went through all
the steps of skepticism
and where the developers were
in the spectrum, because they
were that skeptical.
So what happened is 2001,
a lot of the developers
still were not moving.
They were still not migrating.
And he did a ceremony.
He stood up and he made a vow.
He unfurled an oversized
piece of parchment paper,
and he made a verbal vow that
I will stick with one operating
system strategy.
Some of the developers
hadn't moved,
because they thought
that they were going
to keep jerking them around.
What happened that was
kind of interesting
is in the middle of the
climb, a lot of times
if the s-curves, overlap that's
the time you need to already
be dreaming again.
So the developers
are still moving.
A lot of them had come,
but some pretty big ones
had decided to resist
and decided not to come.
In the meantime, Mr.
Jobs had a new dream.
He was already on
with the Redream.
He had this new vision
that the whole world
of connected devices
would connect
to Mac OS X. It was called
his digital hub strategy.
If you go and you
look at this speech,
he basically prophesied their
entire hardware strategy
for the next decade.
It was a big speech,
so it was a big dream.
So of course, he's
losing his patience.
He's like, get onto X. Get
onto X. He keeps telling them,
get onto X. I got
this new dream.
Oh my God, you're not going
to believe what the world is
going to look like.
So he decides, you know what?
We to bury the old OS.
We need to bury Mac OS 9,
and he did exactly that.
He actually had a coffin and
smoke come up out of the stage,
stained glass up on the
wall, eerie music played.
He came out with an
oversized Mac OS 9,
you can see there to the
right, put it in the coffin,
closed the lid, put
a red rose on it.
And he said a
eulogy for Mac OS 9.
He said, we are here today to
mourn the passing of Mac OS 9.
He is now in that great
bucket in the sky, no doubt
looking down upon us
with that same smile
he displayed every
time he booted.
Mr. Jobs never mentioned Mac
OS 9 again after this day.
It was done.
The developers that
were there-- you
could actually hear
it in the audio.
They're like [NERVOUS CHUCKLE]
are we supposed to laugh
or what?
They'll never forget it.
It was over.
It was done.
So this is a ceremony of
endings and beginnings.
Move on.
He said, language like, the
train has left the station.
People are going to buy
another brand than your brand.
He pushed them out--
endings and beginnings.
He pushed them forward.
Some got pushed out, maybe.
But it is fun to be
a leader, myself.
Some of you might be like,
well, I'm not really a leader.
But I've had the privilege of
being able to prophetically
imagine my own
organization's future
and then had the
power and the autonomy
to move it into this
new alternate future.
And one thing is consistent
is change itself.
I'm sure you've heard that,
but my own organization
is 28 years old.
We're on our eighth reinvention.
That means we have reinvented
ourselves every four years,
which I think is fascinating,
because the US Board of Labor
and Statistics states that small
businesses die between four
and five years.
So it's almost
like the life cycle
of just my own little
unit of 120 people
actually needs to be rejuvenated
in about four year increments.
Now, Google does that at a
scale that this isn't even messy
enough to show.
You guys have hundreds
of venture scapes,
hundreds of them going
on all the time, which
means every single one
of you in this room
are either leading
a venture scape
or you're being impacted
by someone else that's
leading a venture scape.
That means that there's
a lot of other travelers
that need to come
along with you.
You have other people.
These ideas are not
going to be realized
if you can't get others
to come along with you
and make that dream a reality.
It's why learning to
communicate well is so critical.
And you're going to have moments
all the time all along the way
where there's a speech, a story,
a ceremony, bam, bam, bam,
every day a speech.
Oh, I need to tell a story or
I need to do a ceremony today.
You may have a one on one with
one of your direct reports
who's encountered a roadblock.
And you're like, oh, I remember.
And when I did this,
here's the story
of how I overcame that
same roadblock-- a speech.
You got the vision meetings.
You've got the all
hands meetings.
You've got your staff meeting
speeches all the time.
And then there are ceremonies.
Oh my gosh, we just
launched this initiative.
Let's all sign the great
poster that was just made
and make a commitment that we're
going to make this a reality.
Those happen all day long.
But there's these other moments
that happen when the team maybe
missed it.
The team needs to heal.
The team needs to be galvanized.
They need to be rallied.
It's a bigger moment along
all those other moments where
you need to create
collective effervescence,
this moment where the people
are bound to each other
and bound to you and recommitted
what you're asking them to do.
And those stand
out among the rest.
And that's when
you need to combine
the stories, the ceremonies,
and the speeches into a moment
that people will never forget.
Because this is when
they actually recommit.
They're so exhausted,
so beat up,
sometimes they need a moment
to decide, is this worth it?
Can I keep going, and do
I want to keep doing that?
So moving people is really hard.
Just because maybe I have this
skill for seeing the future
doesn't mean I've always been
really good at getting people
to go there.
In fact, I used to just,
at the vision meeting
every year at my
company, I would just
make this epic declaration
of what needed to happen.
And then I would check in with
myself at the end of the year
and be disappointed, sometimes
mostly in my travelers,
that they didn't make
my dream come true,
that I told him once.
And it's so weird just to see
how hard it is to move people.
But I had to finally own.
I was like, why don't
they want to do this?
Why are we not working
together to make this happen?
And I had to realize,
well, maybe it's
partly that the sacrifice is
huge I'm asking them to do.
I have not honored the
fact that maybe they
had to spend more time.
They had to learn new
skills, the sacrifice
they were going to have to
make this dream come true.
But also, was I portraying
it in a way that
made the risk seem worth
the reward to them?
Was the risk worth the reward?
Did I really think for
a minute that they're
encountering these
obstacles that might
be just too hard for them?
And moving them is
really, really hard.
And it's empathy that unlocks
something inside of them.
So I don't and haven't had
that much empathy in my career.
I had to learn it.
And if you look at these two
models we showed you today,
they're actually
models for empathy.
So a leader can actually
think through and see things
from someone else's perspective.
And I was actually
raised by a narcissist.
And a narcissist doesn't
have the empathy gene.
It's actually a mental
illness where the empathy gene
is just vacant.
That means I didn't have
empathy modeled for me as a kid.
My mom never showed me what
that means to think and consider
someone else's perspective.
So my body of work is actually
my own personal journey,
a calling, this thing called
empathy that was evasive to me.
It was gone, and I couldn't
really grasp it or find it.
So I had to create models
so I could see things
from other people's
perspectives.
And I have to confess, I
have opened my own book
that I wrote myself
with Patti, and I've
had to look at the model to do
a couple talks in my own shop.
So it works to consider how
somebody else may be perceiving
what you're asking them
to do and then communicate
through them from that place.
And it is storytelling
that binds us together.
Everything you learn
today, all the models
are based in storytelling.
And I can tell you that
if you adopt the concepts
and principles of story, your
career will never be the same.
It is the very thing
that will move you
from simply a manager
to being a leader,
is how you choose to
communicate the actions you're
wanting others to take on.
That's the sole difference.
Like Patti was
saying, it's a tool.
It's hardwired into our
brains to bind the teller
to the hearer, to the listener.
It binds us to each other.
Storytelling also connects
you with each other.
When you've experienced
an amazing story,
you feel connected
to each other.
And it really changes
the trajectory
of where you're going and how
quickly you can get there.
So if you think
about the concept
of story being
about transforming,
it creates longing.
If people are trying to
change and get somewhere,
the journey is hard.
And it's story that's
the coping mechanism.
It's story that
helps them recommit.
It's story that makes
them want to continue
to build the future
you're portraying
that needs to be built.
Stories create a longing
unlike anything else
in any sort of communications.
So I want to end with
a quote, and then we'll
take questions from you guys.
"If you want to build a ship,
don't drum up people together
to collect wood, and don't
assign them tasks and work,
but rather teach them to long
for the endless immensity
of the sea."
If Google, in principle
and conceptually
would embrace the
power of storytelling--
you guys are already great
and unstoppable-- I can't even
imagine what could become,
because you guys actually
do change the entire world.
And so we would love
to take questions.
We also have a gift
as you leave today.
We brought the actual
insert from the book,
the communication toolkit,
which has "Speeches, Stories
and Ceremonies." and it has
"The Dream, Leap, Fight, Climb,
Arrive."
We have warnings, speeches,
and motivating speeches,
warning stories, motivating
stories, warning ceremonies,
motivating ceremonies.
Whip this out.
Use it as your map, and
change the world like crazy.
So we'd love to take questions.
If you want to shout
them out, we'll
repeat it for the recording
if anyone has questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I've been invited to different
professional conferences.
And often they invite me to
talk about some topics that
are quite similar, not really
new concepts or new practices,
but talking about things that
people really are already
know, just sort of
reminders, refreshers,
trying to reinspire people.
But the research is the same.
If we're talking about
mentorship or the best
practices in the
HR community-- I'm
actually in people ops-- it's
really similar information.
You go to a conference.
You're hearing this information.
I would say half
of those stories
are personal stories
that are new,
but the information that's
backing is really the same.
So making that move and
making that transformation,
the research is out there.
People know the research, and
so instead of just restating it,
I think, yes.
We need to do this.
We need to do this right away.
But what would you suggest
in terms of an approach
to reviving the research
that's out there?
NANCY DUARTE: Reviving
stale research?
PATTI SANCHEZ: Gosh, that's
a really good question.
I guess would it be too
simplistic for me to say,
storytelling is an
approach to do that.
There's a way to
find a new narrative
in the data that's out there.
And certainly by connecting
it to current situations
that illustrate
those principles.
I think in people ops, I
think in a lot of fields,
there's sort of an attraction
to shining new objects,
whatever the trend is
is what-- the book that
starts to sell off the shelves,
something that seems like it's
got a new hook but it really
is rooted in things people
already know.
And in some ways, I think
storytelling is like that.
NANCY DUARTE: You know what
I have to do for myself?
I speak enough where I want
it to be interesting to me
so I'm enthused
when I deliver it.
So sometimes I just throw
in different examples
or startle myself or
something because I
have to stay interested
in my own material.
And people can see when
you're enthused or not.
So it's like, oh, I'm
tired of this story.
I'll tell you it again.
So I think a lot
of it has to come
from here, a place of
passion instead of here,
a place of knowledge.
And people can feel it.
I can feel it when
I'm delivering it
from my heart versus
delivering it from my mind.
And the really cool thing about
being with people in person
is presentations are one
of the few times when
you can connect face to face.
So you could go and get eyeballs
and search results and clicks
and all of that.
But when you're actually in
the room with people, in a way
that you can actually create a
really deep human connection,
using stories, using
personal stories,
using new and fresh ways to
connect them to the information
while you're in person,
it makes you unstoppable.
So that was a good question.
That was a really good question.
AUDIENCE: So first
of all, thank you
both so much for coming
and visiting with us here.
I want to talk to you about
and ask you about your process.
I want to learn
about your process
in two different settings.
One is when you're in the
act of making a presentation
and what is the chain of
things that you go through when
you're doing this yourself?
But secondly also, as you
talk about storytelling,
it involves connecting the
dots from several different
experiences in the past.
So I guess that needs
you to become a learning
machine over time.
What is your process for
things that you see every day?
Do you make notes?
How do you--
NANCY DUARTE: Good question.
PATTI SANCHEZ: Yeah, really.
Well, I guess so answering
the first question
about our process, when
thinking about a presentation
or any form of
communication for me,
I always start
with the audience.
And it's also the
Duarte methodology
to empathize with the people
that you're communicating to.
And it's sort of
counterintuitive,
because usually the thing
you're clearest about right away
is what you want to say.
This is my subject matter.
This is the information
I want to get across.
And the problem is,
if you start with that
as your framework, first of
all, you're not necessarily
going to communicate in the
best possible way for people
to understand it and embrace it.
And second of all, ego
can get in the way.
And that can be a problem too.
So our methodology and when
we work with our clients
to build presentations
or help them communicate
their story on any level is
to start by empathetically
understanding their audience.
Who are they?
What are they feeling?
What are they thinking?
What are they likely to resist?
What are the reasons they
might like this idea?
And then use that to help
us decide what we say
and what we don't say and
then also how to structure it.
I'll let you take the other
question about the learning
machine and gather your stories.
NANCY DUARTE: I'm sure you
guys have heard the mindset
concepts of being a lifelong
learner versus someone who
just checks in.
I think Google's hiring process
filters out the people that
aren't lifelong learners.
But I would say we are vast
consumers of information.
To your point on research,
Patti and I have, I think,
three banker boxes that
we printed of research
and then who knows?
I think we read the internet,
pretty much the whole thing
and found patterns
that had never
been seen before and insight.
And it's just that
hunger and quest
for how much more can we
have storytelling change us?
And I think in that
quest for learning,
you're transformed yourself.
And I would say stay hungry.
Stay foolish is super
important to do if you
want to become something.
There's a whole lot
of people that do just
want to skate through life
and live on the system
or live on a system or just
be plugged in to the matrix.
Maybe not that system.
But yeah, it's
just a mindset that
will turn you from an individual
contributor to manager
to leader.
It's all a mindset.
One of the reasons we
use the term torchbearer,
because it's a mantle.
Being a leader is a mantle.
You're offered opportunities
to lead all day.
Like, Frodo had the
little ring fall
on his hand and
he's like, holy cow.
Do I want to deal
with this or do I not?
You're given a choice.
And leadership's like that.
it's like a mantle.
And a lot of people
self-select out of leading.
They self-select
out, and they choose
to not follow, go into
the fire of Sauron.
That is kind of scary, right?
There's a lot of interesting
hardships in choosing to be
a leader, but the ones that
communicate well have less
hardships than the
ones that don't.
AUDIENCE: So a gentle
follow-up, if I may.
You mentioned printing out
tons of research and so on.
NANCY DUARTE: We
only killed one tree.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Silent motivation
behind my question
here was with the internet and
knowledge becoming so much more
accessible, there's
also the concept
of information overload.
And in your works, and every
time you do so much research,
I was wondering, how
do you balance learning
versus information overload?
NANCY DUARTE: We had a
round of this that we did
and we pasted it up on the wall.
We were real excited, and we
brought one of our key clients
in.
And he was like, holy cow.
You guys have, like,
six books in here.
You need to-- it's hard to
murder your own darlings,
right?
And you would get really
attached to stuff, especially
when it's research-based.
Because there were things
where I was like, for sure?
We spent two months on
this one concept we cut.
Two people times
two months cutting.
That was hard, but it was right.
And so you get so deep
you lose perspective.
And we actually had other
people come in and slash
and slash and slash.
And we have some beautiful stuff
that's hit the cutting room
floor that we're
just now next week,
we're going away for the
whole week, to my house,
to examine the things that got
cut to see if we can plant that
and it blooms into
something new.
But cutting it,
slashing that stuff-- I
have a photo of her where
we pasted it up on the wall.
PATTI SANCHEZ: It was like
"Home Alone." [SCREAMS]
Very upsetting.
NANCY DUARTE: We literally
took the whole thing.
And it was two months
before deadline.
We cut half the
book and rebuilt it.
It was unbelievable.
PATTI SANCHEZ: But it was
the right thing to do,
and what motivated it was a
desire to help the reader.
The feedback that we
got from the people
that we tested the ideas with,
that's what gave me conviction
to let go of some things that
I was really attached to.
Because it was more
important to me
that they walk
away with something
that's valuable to them
than to satisfy myself.
NANCY DUARTE: Showcase that
we printed the internet wasn't
as important.
PATTI SANCHEZ: Some of
it came from in here too.
It wasn't all out
in the internet.
Any other questions
from you guys?
Hope it is a really hard,
challenging question out there.
NANCY DUARTE: Or you guys just
want to get back to your job
and be torchbearers.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious to hear about some
of the company reinventions
you went through.
NANCY DUARTE: Yeah.
So believe it or
not, a lot of people
think I started the
company, but my husband did.
1987, he worked his
butt off all summer
moving furniture from a
failing aerospace company.
And he saved enough
to buy a Mac.
And he started doing
technical illustrations.
So he was a freelancer working
from home in his underwear,
kids underfoot,
loving it, right?
And then I joined him in
1990, pick up the phone,
and in one afternoon
won three huge accounts.
So I don't go back
to my real job.
We become a service bureau I
actually had a 35 millimeter
slide imager.
People don't even
know what that was.
Cost us 20 grand.
Here we are in this crappy
apartment in Sunnyvale,
with yellow shag carpet.
And we have a $20,000
thing that makes slides.
Every penny we made, we
stuck back in the business.
So we became a service
bureau, and then we
became a design firm.
And then the dotcom
crash happened.
Good to Great came
out, and Good to Great
had a hedgehog concept.
And it said, if there's
one thing you can do,
you can be best in
the world at, be
profitable at and passionate
about, do just that one thing.
So here was a season where
the economy had crashed,
and I did the most
counterintuitive dream,
re-dream of my business
ever, is I completely
shut the door on print and web.
And we did just
presentations, the one thing
that we could focus on.
So then we became a
niche, and then we
became best in the world when
we produced our material.
And then we decided to
become best in the world
at business storytelling.
And then you can
see-- and now we're
in leading through stories.
So you can see the migration
of how that happened.
PATTI SANCHEZ: And
we're not done yet.
NANCY DUARTE: And
The cool thing is, we moved in
two years ago to the building
that my husband moved
furniture from in 1987.
So the building we're in, and
then the four buildings to 101
are the ones that he
moved furniture from.
PATTI SANCHEZ: One
of the things that I
love about that story, the
transformation around 2001
and focusing on presentations
is saying no to other things.
Nancy talked about
the importance
of endings and beginnings.
And I think that's
actually one of the hardest
things about
reinvention of yourself
or anything that you're working
on is saying no to something,
leaving that something behind.
But it's also freeing too,
lets you do bigger things.
NANCY DUARTE: So if someone
has a burning question
and throws their hands
up, we'll take it.
Otherwise, you guys get to go.
Rehydrate and get ready
for your next thing.
So here's your toolkits,
and thank you so much
for your time, guys.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]